good evening it's my huge pleasure and
honor to introduce to you our dinner
speaker a dear friend of mine dan rose
let me begin with Dan's business
exploits in some venues maybe the
organizers wouldn't dream of citing the
business exploits of the dinner speaker
but this is the center on capitalism and
society and we have no problem about
that whatsoever there dan Rose has had
an extraordinarily successful business
career career as a businessman in New
York Boston and Arlington or may we say
Washington DC ice perhaps best known for
his hand in the development of the
pentagon city complex in Virginia along
the blue and yellow lines of the
Washington Metro completed in 2009 an
award-winning urban village of hyper i
rise luxurious apartments and condos as
well as the fashion center mall another
major project of his is the building of
one financial center in downtown boston
in 1983 the third tallest building in
boston when measuring by pinnacle height
which helped anchor the redevelopment of
that city I remember having a lunch with
Dan not so long ago in which he said
that that part that the desirability the
profitability of that project was
obvious I like that schumpeter would
have been happy and in New York one can
add to his accomplishments for just for
starters the creation of the housing but
for the performing arts that is linked
manhattan plaza opened with a ribbon
cutting ceremony in 1977 uh personally I
must say that when Viviana and I are
walking around the city we can't get
more than a few blocks without seeing a
rose here or Rose there arose there it's
absolutely amazing what he has
contributed to the city as a
philanthropist he has contributed to the
flourishing of New York through his
co-founding of programs such as the
harlem educational activities fun
helping thousands of inner-city youth to
enter college since 1989 and the
establishment of initiatives including
the Rose Center for Public leadership
the joint Yale technion Rose Homeland
Security and counterterrorism program
the Jacobs technion Cornell Institute at
Cornell Tech and the helping Africa
foundation of which is president I could
go on and on and on about the
innumerable boards on which he serves
but uh let's let's just say that he is
the most illustrious benefit benefactor
that New York City and and not just New
York City have have ever had so it's a
an extraordinary pleasure to invite dan
to give this dinner speech and and and
and when you've heard it you will know
how how how valuable he is thank
[Applause]
friends forget all that that's for your
obituary forget all that friends we've
been party to a thought-provoking
exhilarating stimulating exercise today
for which I'm sure we're all grateful to
the center which plays such an important
part in stimulating thinking in
clarifying issues this Center has always
been necessary in these difficult times
it will be more necessary than ever and
we should be grateful for it we should
encourage it support it this Center is
going to be salvation this Center and
groups like it will be our salvation in
the future
[Applause]
hey
now I came prepared with a talk that Ned
had read and that he liked but in the
course of the day it seemed clear to me
that the talk that I have prepared and
written out and we'll be happy to send
to anyone who wishes was the right
answer to the wrong question because the
conference today our discussion has been
on working class and and middle class
responses the the talk that I prepared
that I am happy to send to you gave the
right answer to the wrong question the
questions the paper deals with the
challenges to our socio-economic system
the need for long-term solutions not
short-term fixes the need for continuing
significant economic growth on the one
hand we need a bigger pie but we need a
fairer more rational distribution of the
incremental growth components and then
finally we need more institutions that
are healthy and vibrant and serve our
needs and they can come from the support
of groups like the center on capitalism
and society so that's that that was a
brief summary of this paper many page
paper that I'll be happy to send you as
we were listening all day I am prepared
to give you a talk that I will be
writing up tomorrow because I'm all
psyched up all right that the subject
that I wouldn't my title is going to be
to a group of economists who think in
terms of that which can be quantified
and men
jerk I'm the title for my paper on the
class situation we were discussing is
broke versus poor being broke is in
economic condition lacking funds for
people who are broke their tendency is
to pull up their socks and become
unbroke as quickly as possible being
poor is a more complex situation most of
whose participants or members were poor
are poor and will be poor so the
difference in terms of working class
social class is a significant difference
in attitude and mindset which economists
don't tend to focus on now in terms of
working and middle-class you've had had
people like Robert Putnam on the left
and charles Murray on the right
discussing the nuances but they go with
attitudes and values now Ned mentioned
Manhattan Plaza which i think is a
fascinating case history that economists
can focus on in terms of broke versus
poor because that's when I first used
the phrase a group called hrh
construction had developed this program
and they retained my company to be upon
a fee basis to provide the renting and
managing services and in that year 1977
my people were very anxious to get those
fees lo and behold there was a market
crash housing market evaporated and the
mortgagee wanted to stop construction
of this middle-income housing
development on forty-second Street and
tenth Avenue because it couldn't be it
couldn't succeed the only program that
would permit it to go ahead was called
section eight the lowest possible income
level and people were outraged they
refused to have what in effect was
public housing on the heart of the
theater district they thought laundry
hanging out over the balconies thugs and
hoodlums coming that was my problem
because my company were going to be the
renting and managing agents and my
people said they needed those fees so
the developers problem became mine and I
proposed yes it can be housing for
section 8 low low income levels but only
for members of the Screen Actors Guild
the act of the Musicians Union actors
equity they all had to have professional
credentials as well as having low income
and in short that turned out to be the
solution broke but not poor economic
justification but they were all
graduates of the Yale School of Drama or
whatever an interesting situation came
that's at 1977 after the building was
occupied that year there was an
electrical shortage in electrical crisis
in New York a blackout per couple of
days there was no electricity in
Manhattan in public housing throughout
the city there were murders there were
robberies there were rapes
at Manhattan Plaza the tenants
themselves organized a self-help group
the people on the lower floors planted
candles on November no elect no
elevators no lights the people on the
lower floors planted candles on all the
stairways going up every step in every
stairway the people in the lower ten
floors volunteered to have people in the
upper floors as much as the 35th floor
to come down and sleep on couches in
their living rooms they moved over they
made accommodation there were no
problems no cases of rape difficulty a
middle class group of people without
money demonstrated how they react in a
low-income setting it was a perfect
example of what social class in terms of
robert putnam and charles murray in
terms of what ed Banfield thought about
future mindedness to being a sign of
close social class at Banfield a friend
used to be at Harvard felt that social
class is a function not of finances but
of your sense of the future that the
dysfunctional poor can think through the
end of the week that the fruit pickers
can think through the end of the fruit
picking season working-class think
through a few years middle class want to
educate their children upper middle
class build family buildings patricians
sit and we no longer have patricians
today but Banfield said patricians think
of what's best for the society and it's
all a sense of time frame
based on ed Banfield's thinking when I
created the Harlem educational
activities fund this is for black
Central Harlem poor public school
students we pounded away on future
mindedness we said every child must have
a view where do you want to be in 10
years where do you want to be in 20
years and then you have to focus today
desperately on your efforts to get there
we ever we were short of it wasn't words
we told them life is a marathon run but
in the short term you have to sprint on
Monday sprint on Tuesday sprint on
Wednesday and you'll end up winning the
marathon sharply focused effort now is
this is the answer for a long-term goal
of our children black children public
school ebony magazine this black
magazine this current issue has an
article on my program calling it without
peer in the United States it points out
ebony magazine that nationwide eleven
percent of all american high school
students go on to graduate school of our
children thirty-five percent go on one
hundred percent graduate high school one
hundred percent go on to four-year
colleges thirty-five percent go on to
graduate school because their future
minded they have the self-confidence the
disciplined effort and the vision of the
future that's what social class
demonstrates I
one of the proudest moments of my life
came a few years ago when I and I just
spoke with this girl yesterday because
we keep in touch the daughter of the
non-english speaking Dominican which
means colored single mother daughter of
a non-english-speaking Dominican single
mother had invited us to her
commencement at Yale University where
she graduated magna laude later in
the day we burst with pride when our
little girl received Yale has a number
of residential colleges her college was
Timothy Dwight college and this child
this young girl had her name inscribed
on the Timothy Dwight College masters
cup for her contribution to the life of
Yale University another girl written up
in this ebony magazine this current
issue is a child from a dysfunctional
inner-city Harlem family who says in the
article in the interview how she owes
everything to heap she has just
graduated from the army US Army's
command and general staff college and is
they going to be this month she's being
promoted to lieutenant colonel this girl
one of our girls is going to be a black
female general in the US Army we chatted
with her while back and she made the
comment she wasn't the smartest one in
her family she said her brother really
was the smart one I I don't know why I
asked where is your brother now
and she said oh he's in prison her two
younger sisters are welfare single
mothers the one that we worked with and
whose value system we influenced is
going to be a black female general so in
terms of mindset we have to think in
terms of the value system the
aspirations the sense of self confidence
and the ability to achieve that's what a
social class can be and that has to be
taken into consideration on all the the
programs of dealing with social class
it's not pure economics now the other
things we was going to discuss is the
question of work my father used to like
the expression that work is what because
we've heard that seventy percent of the
people in America are going to be
unemployed in 2045 my father used to say
that work is what you do not enjoy
whether you're paid for it or not that
play is what you do enjoy whether you're
paid for it or not and my father said
the Blessed of the earth go through life
playing while being handsomely rewarded
for it that means engaging in activities
that are meaning and satisfying and
fulfilling and that is the challenge we
have how if we have a growing economy
and that's one of our problems how to
have the steady increase in growth how
do we divide and distribute the proceeds
more fairly and rationally so that we
can provide for all young
bo activities whether professional or
unprofessional whether vocational or ex
or out of their exit out of their
professional activities that permit them
to lead satisfying and fulfilling lives
that's the goal of our society a society
that's fair that gives upward upward
opportunity and the chance for people to
grow to their full height and that's
what we have to do in terms of all of
our goals for everybody now in terms of
some of the comments made during the day
let me just say quickly about Donald
Trump supporters and Trump is a
traumatic experience a national
humiliation and national embarrassment a
national travel about the Trump
supporters I could only think after the
this traumatic experience of hearing his
election Lennon Lennon commented with
contempt about the common people Lennon
said the people shout bread bread and to
accentuate their demands they burn the
bakeries burning the bakeries is going
to be I hope and pray we all have to
wish this man well because he's our
leader I despair that I will not live to
see the next time we have a liberal
Supreme Court but thanks to institutions
like this Center for capitalism we have
to be helpful we have to be constructive
we have to be Her Majesty's loyal
opposition
when they when it's called for and be
supportive and cooperative when that is
called for now many people are sad today
one of the facts of life and it is a
fact is Paul Valerie's comment that the
future is not what it used to be.we used
to think more constructively of the
future once again we have to change
reverse gears we have to think more
constructively so that the future once
again can be a constructive one now it
can be if groups play an active part if
groups like the center and their
colleagues and all of us play active
constructive roles nothing worthwhile
just happens and if we need a theme
about our activities both the center
comparable groups each of us in our
respective roles we have two good things
can happen we have to think of the
comment of Oliver Wendell Holmes jr. who
said and this can be our watchword the
mode by which the inevitable comes to
pass is called effort our effort can
help good things come to pass thank you
[Applause]
I think I think I think den would be
agreeable to a question or two if if
there are questions or comments would
any of you like to offer a question or
comment yes no we start at the 6th grade
all we require is that a child at the
6th grade can read and write now that's
a lot but the child has to read and
write the parents have to be
constructive we all we ask is that a
parent be supportive and the child has
to be amenable to our pep talks and our
high aspirations but my point is that
there can be positive self-fulfilling
prophecies as well as negative that's
the challenge of the society how to give
young people positive self-fulfilling
prophecies and that's what we do from
the age of from the 6th grade on and the
other questions yes yes Simon
Mike's coming how many children have you
been able to help in your program over a
thousand children and we're now we have
them up our home is at the old hotel
Teresa on 125th streak in Central Harlem
we've just opened a branch at Bedford
Stuyvesant in Brooklyn where we're
dealing with these the worst school
district in the city and we believe we
can change the mindset we can change the
value system of these children and
thereby change their lives yes
listen more detail on your program
because I think it's admirable what
you're doing you get them to live
together how do you spot them how do you
create these values in them do you put
them in a common common educational
system or how how does it work this is
an after-school program they go to
regular public school this is in
addition to not instead of we are
psyching them up we pound away on the
fact that learning is the key teaching
is what some teacher does at a
blackboard we pound the way to our
children that learning is what takes
place in their heads it's their
responsibility to read to write to count
to speak effectively to think clearly
and rationally and outside the box our
job is to help them we give them a sense
of personal responsibility that's what
like we deal with the concept that
education is not something you put into
a passive receptacle education is
stimulating the child's thinking and
these children can go on and achieve
great things so this is the challenge we
all have how to have personally
professionally organizationally
constructive self-fulfilling prophecies
for the future a runner who thinks he's
going to lose
the race will lose the race a runner who
thinks he may win has a vastly better
chance so this is the way we have to do
in terms of our society not optimistic
but hopeful hopeful and working hard to
make those hopes material lungs Saskia
was your hand up saskia sassen yeah Dan
you know that Richard and I have long
been great admirers of you and Johanna
and how do we get the new generation of
real estate developers in New York City
to add to their project which you have
described to us which is truly admire
about and very significant well we try
to inculcate we're great belabor
believers in praise versus blame in
pride in giving people the encouragement
those act people we no longer deal with
the question in our society of pride vs
shame we teach our children to be
embarrassed to be ashamed of doing less
than well we teach them pride in
achievement now this is considered bad
form in our society I think that's
madness we include the high aspirations
and we cheer them all and they pride
they proud they are proud of their
achievements and their friends and
colleagues our pride are proud of them
so a having a clear vision of what the
goals should be
achievement be inculcating the
self-confidence step by step we start
very young giving them reasons for
self-confidence and realization that
hard work pays off and it gradually
comes and they pass the test this is not
an affirmative action concept we do not
believe in equality of result we believe
in equality of opportunity and the
opportunities should be available and
should the encouragement and the
stimulus of Napoleon Bonaparte said that
every French soldier should feel that he
has the Battle of a marshal of France
down said gee bear in his knapsack das
aves mg burn every French soldier should
feel he could be a marshal of France
we're just taking a leap from napoleon's
book now the den is getting fully warmed
up how about how about some more
questions
well yes yeah go ahead are you you're
going to the bathroom oh no thank you hi
I'm Ethan park on the student here at
the University I have a question for you
regarding the values aspect of your
speech tonight I went to a high school
that also prided itself very strongly on
values and every single day we hear in
some capacity the need for values in
particular honor integrity respect
humility and excellence those are the
vibe and you know again what you're
doing with young people starting at
great sex it's very admiring inspiring
to me but what can you say with regards
to people let's say who are you know
maybe in their 40s 50s 60s and have
maybe a set of values that are different
than the ones you're trying to inculcate
do you think that you know for people of
that age there's an opportunity to
affect the same change via dialogue or
via you know some sort of open
conversation how do you think or do you
think that is something that can be
achieved and if so how might one go
about doing that well the the
discussions today really dealt in this
last session of two separate questions
one social class but also regional
problems regional problems should be
dealt with nationally and a Hillary
Clinton should have said not that if she
should not have referred
her to Donald Trump supporters as
deplorable giving that whole voter group
to Donald Trump she should have said
ekin free trade is benefits the entire
macro society however some parts of the
economy pay the price we must help those
areas that are her we must help retrain
those people who are displaced we must
every other your advanced European
country has vocational training programs
job training programs efforts to help
people adjust every other advanced
nation has those and we must have them
to giving people an opportunity and
understanding not everybody can go to
college we have to give vocational
opportunities for people to have careers
that are satisfying and productive and
fulfilling so that they feel a sense of
accomplishment they feel they've
achieved something and they feel they're
living up to their their productivity
their productive possibilities one self
image does not have to depend on a
relative status based on an economic
route that's a key factor how to make
people feel valued how to make them feel
that they have a place a mission of
purpose and and another factor that we
do encourage is questioning this is
something that isn't frequently
discussed you have two forms of
educational influence in the world today
you have the Confucian and you have what
the woman if another term I'll call Jai
the Jewish or Israeli Singapore is the
kate is the poster child for confusion
education something like seven million
people and Singapore Israel has
virtually the same number in Singapore
the children start early and late work
fiercely hard memorize everything in
sight Jewish children in Israel are told
constantly the question question
question Confucian children Revere their
professors they adore them but they
never questioned Singapore confusion no
question is real constant questioning
since the year to that both about seven
or eight million people or whatever
since the year 2000 how many Nobel
prizes has Singapore 10 how many Nobel
prizes has Israel one I think it's seven
or eight one inculcates questioning
rabbi Hillel says this rabbi Shammai
says that what do you think no there are
no black and white open and shut answers
in Israeli instigation and they're
constantly questioning that's one of the
things that we encourage our Harlem
children to do constant questioning
open-mindedness with the self confidence
that they can achieve great things thank
you
[Applause]
without that Mike what
how does computer technology factor into
your approach we do that through the
schools we encourage them but we are not
a computer oriented we just expose them
and we encourage them to take outside
computer courses where we're more
interested in the psyche of stimulus
than in the mechanics of it thank you
we're going to have to wrap up now I
want to thank Dan rose for this
inspiring talk I love this man and I'm
very grateful to you Dan for for joining
us all day long and at this dinner
thanks a lot
[Music]